good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
today we are learning stocks with tick
tocks it's the throwback thursday to
last week
guys i have to pay respect to that pump
uh the video did very well and
we need to recreate that right look
everybody knows the best investing
advice is on tick tock forget about the
traditional investors they're
losing billions of dollars to wall
street bets you got to go
to where the new money is baby it's not
in hedge funds
it's in robin hood traders guys who are
ready to blow up their account so
let's watch this together we're gonna
get 10
tips okay count them ted rule
number one to start us off just hot how
to make one million dollars in four
months
this should be good he wants us to do
what make an account
put in bitcoin of course then oh look at
this
time to make money red button is for
sale and
green is to buy buy low sell
is this a repeat of last week i see a
stock going up and i buy it
and i just watch it until it stops going
up and then i sell it and i do that over
and over and it pays for our whole
lifestyle no
dude you can't just buy low and sell
highs just time the market guys
stay consistent for four months and you
now have 4.6 million dollars
yeah guys just go uh spin the roulette
wheel 20 times in a row you have four
million dollars start with fifty dollars
instead it's that
easy guys when you're on tick tock
you're making some bucks baby that's
rule number one time to market and
always be consistent four months never
lose
rule number two okay we're getting a
little bit different here we got an
ipo tip so tomorrow is doordash's ipo
stop playing copyrighted music please
i'm trying to react to these things and
you guys are killing me
a lot of you guys have been asking what
i think about it so it looks like it's
going to open up between 90 to 95
dollars
i think it's a great investment for a
long term i'm not sure how it's going to
be right away for options but for a long
term
ipos are very interesting all they can
do is go up wait what
you guys know ipos they only go up
number two always invest in ipos they
can only go up
rule number three let's take a look i
want everybody to get access to their
[ __ ] 401k
and embed it all on the patriots plus
five
this pick will not lose we are not in
this business to lose hit us up on hey
the pick will not lose okay let's look
up that pick how did that do betting
everything on the patriots can i
hey cannot lose you should always trust
a guy with this kind of mustache
hey who calls their barber and goes hey
give me the pencil okay
give me the pencil this
this pencil cannot lose baby what's it
say what what's the final score
oh oops someone tell pencil lip over
here
you guys just lost a lot of money hey so
step rule three
from from stocks with dick docks uh
bet everything on the patriots every
time cannot lose sports betting never
loses
i don't have a lot of time so i'm just
going to give you all the math right so
if you have 25 000
in any brokerage bank account right you
do margins now the only thing is with
margins it's kind of like
debt but it doesn't need to be used at
that sometimes it can be used as
collateral
meaning that if you want to sell a call
option
and you can get into why you need
collateral to get sell a call option
and get a margin account when you get 25
000 you're buying power increases
okay let me stop this guy because i know
exactly who this is this
there's several traders like this right
they're uh
slightly too smart for their own good
and they get themselves confused
and they go this cannot possibly go tits
up and every time
it turns into a disaster just four times
so you really get the buying power of a
hundred thousand meaning your collateral
is a hundred thousand
now when you shorter stock you can make
safely
one percent to two percent of your
buying power you could well you know
you know understand if you if you just
short the stock
uh okay rule number four
you want to take out margin as
collateral that's that's the rule number
four take out margin
as collateral let's see what rule five
is all about
just how to trade you bout to make a lot
of money bro
[Music]
whoa bro you asked the right guy you
came to the right guy
to learn how to trade first go to
tradingview.com step two
find a currency pair right now i'm on
usd cad so this
is an impulse retracement impulse
retracement impulse retrace one strategy
that i use to trade is simply trying to
predict
these retracements
it's easy guys just pretty hey just
predict which way the market will go
it's that easy i mean listen when you're
done betting your 401k
on the pats you want to go and put in
all
of the retracements listen guys
technical analysis
it's been proven to be a very real thing
been back tested always makes money
you know uh every single time so just
that's it
rule five take the technical analysis
always works
rule six the inflation rate is not two
and a half to three percent
it's eight percent on average the index
funds
the s p 500 and the nasdaq and all that
they do about eight percent per year
only that the wealthiest people in the
country are compounding
look how confident he is ah i can't take
it anymore dude
can we just look that up the inflation
rate of the us 2020. it's 0.62
this year it was 2 last year 2 percent
look at how confident and wrong this man
is at the same time this is
this is impressive hey so just state
stuff confidently that's that's rule
number six be confident believe in
yourself dude
we should none of us realize or very few
of us realize is that
they put like 90 of their income back
into the market
it's pennies this guy's eyebrows are
always like guys
nobody realizes that the inflation rate
is eight percent
nobody nobody but me i actually i i'm in
my bathroom right now but
i'm paying pay no attention to that i am
the smartest guy on wall street
it's pennies and if you look at the fund
that you invested in and it only did
eight percent
you just broke even well okay nobody's
investing in the s p
500 and tick tock come on let's be
honest dude
rule seven who's this guy oh stock
market versus real estate
i wonder which one he's gonna pick here
uh because this is stocks with
tick tocks so he better pick the right
one here's the difference between
investing in the stock market
versus real estate here is how it feels
to invest in the stock market
one hour you can be feeling good and
then you're down and then you're up and
then you're down i mean this could be
every minute
or every second just like that it's like
you're laying at the hospital bed
they monitor your heartbeats and you
don't know when the game
will be just a casual death reference
that's all it is
the game is over over come on
come on oh minch
let's get a replay will be over come on
man
[ __ ] now here's real estate with real
estate
you start here and then you'll just
slowly slowly
go up real estate only goes up guys
this man man's been asleep during 2008
apparently he didn't exist he was born
after 2008.
uh yet that's not how anything works
buddy i'm
sorry to say it's real real estate like
this hey stocks
until you die i guess rule number seven
don't ever invest in stocks forget
everything we've learned
invest in real estate every time because
it only to the moon
only to the moon there's no such thing
as overpriced real estate only to the
moon
solve the economic crisis on msnbc oh
this is exciting actually this is
because this is real news unlike the
fake news you see on youtube
who is this the rachel rachel's got the
news for us
i wonder just what you what you make of
this very last minute um scramble
of of what we thought was going to
proceed here with this relief bill
yeah hey rachel thanks for having me on
i just don't understand why we're not
printing more money
like we have a printing plan
right that prints money just run the
machines a couple of extra hours
each night oh
gosh we really do have the worst
education in the world i swear
i i mean i'm assuming this is maybe a
troll
but i i do actually think there are some
people that think like this they're like
hey why don't you turn the money
machines on
uh i guess world number eight is print
more money not a bad rule to be quite
honest
rule number nine so i bought a stock but
then it started going down
so i sold it but then it started going
up
so i bought it again but then it started
going down again
but i thought it would start going up
again so i bought more of it
but then it just kept going down so i
sold it
hey hey this is the relatable tick tock
investor rule
number nine that's actually the opposite
of world number one this is invest high
sell oh so yeah actually rule one and
rule nine are very fitting because
they're sort of like
the expectations versus reality you
think that you're just gonna be able to
perfectly time the market
and then the reality is this guy right
here
here's our last expert okay from tick
tock this guy apparently has a million
subscribers so we're saving the best for
last okay
hey xander let me tell you a story i
need to be discreet about it so let's
call it
b coin oh see you're talking about
bitcoin all right got it that's too
obvious let's call it
bit c so one day the rich people wanted
to be more rich
so they made this thing up called a
bitsy and they convinced the non-rich
people
that one day it'd be worth over a
hundred thousand yeah guys that's what
the rich people did they convinced
you all to invest early so then they
could get in late that's that's why
all these banks are buying up bitcoin
it's the rich conspiracy thousand
dollars
so the non-rich people bought into it
and made the rich people even more rich
even though it's completely made up dude
i love the confidence of this guy
i'm just gonna start walking around like
this hey guys hey
can you see this hey so
let me tell you what's going on every
meeting from now on
i'm going to be honest with you i'm
going to need double the money listen i
want to be rich
you're non-rich you're going to give me
the money right now people discovered it
was completely made up so the price
started going down so what the rich
people do
they bought it back at a discount but
then they posted articles on forbes
and yahoo saying it was going to be
worth 500 000
this is like a bad meme you'd see from
2017 you think this was from back then
no dude this was recently this guy is an
idiot
and you know what else i looked into
this guy
curtis he's not just hating on bitcoin
he also hates
s p 500 um he says a roth ira is a waste
of your time guys a million followers
on tick tock he says that's a waste your
time what should you do instead
index universal life insurance with his
company everything's a scam
index universal life with his company
not a camp open your mind
[ __ ] bought into it again and the cycle
of manipulation starts all over again
i love how this guy is telling the story
about how your the non-rich are getting
manipulated by the rich
when this is a rich guy who owns a
company
shilling this one type of financial
product and he's telling non-rich people
he's going everyone needs to invest in
what i'm doing otherwise what they're
doing is the scam
i love it so step 10 sell your
crappy investment product and everything
else is a scam s p 500 scam 401k
scam roth ira scam suncor's
universal life insurance that baby hey
that's what i'm talking about
the mri you got to take out leverage
baby try to understand it please
you can make 10 a year every year baby
but either way guys whether you believe
in bitcoin or not i i don't really
care i mean you can think of the scam i
just find it funny that this guy's
shilling his own product while saying
everything else is a scam uh but i hope
you enjoyed
these stocks stock tips with tick tocks
you know these guys are the future
of wall street may god have mercy on our
souls
uh all of this was pulled from once
again tick tock investors on twitter
we'll put
up a little logo right here uh big shout
out to them they're hilarious i follow
them they're one of my favorite twitter
accounts right now
they're incredible go follow them look
the the month's almost over what will
happen can i continue will i go bald
find out hope you enjoyed and i'll see
you
[Music]
tomorrow
you